nearly 50 years after the last american
troops left vietnam president biden
awarded the medal of honor yesterday to
four men for their service in that war
the president praised them for their
incredible heroism in defending our
nation and our values all four had
received lower level decorations but now
they hold america's highest military
honor the president called it the full
recognition they deserve david martin
tells their stories
this is what dwight birdwell's tank
looked like at the end of a battle
against the vietcong on occasion i stood
on top of the tank with my m16 rifle
to fire at the enemy best way to get
yourself killed i didn't want to die but
i wanted to do my job and that was more
important
if i didn't do it everybody was going to
perish when he was ordered to load onto
the medevac helicopter he complied
this i find amazing only to crawl right
back off the other side
and keep on fighting
president biden awarded the medal of
honor to four vietnam veterans whose
valor was not properly recognized at the
time
today
we're setting the record straight it's
just astounding when you hear what each
of them have done dennis fujii went into
laos to rescue south vietnamese troops
pinned down by the enemy he summed up
his valor with one of the great
understatements of the war i like my job
i like to help other people who need
help out there edward canishiro was
killed in vietnam
his daughter naomi remembers when her
mother got the news she never did speak
of her father never i believe it's
because
the grief was so profound for her
his son john accepted the medal he
ordered his men to take cover and then
he advanced alone toward the enemy
position
armed with six grenades in his m16
retired green beret john duffy was the
lone american fighting alongside badly
outnumbered south vietnamese troops we
had a total of 471 including myself how
many made it out was 37. duffy was
ordered to leave his south vietnamese
troops and save himself they wanted no
american casualties if they could
prevent him which made no sense to me so
i advised him
i will be the last man out
and now the last man out wears the
nation's highest military honor for cbs
mornings david martin washington
powerful words i will be the last man
out it's so wonderful to see these
vietnam veterans getting the recognition
that is long overdue because you know we
talk a lot about the greatest generation
world war ii veterans oftentimes we
leave off the vietnam war veterans
because it's a war that america
ultimately ended up not doing so well in
and um it's great that finally after all
these years it's never too late to
recognize recognize those heroes that
sacrificed everything in in some cases
58 thousand americans killed in that one
believable unbelievable stories